Ukrainians do believe. John
Erica. Natasha really appreciate
the reporting. Thank you. This
morning. Chinese president XI
jinping is back in China
following a three day summit
with Russian president Vladimir
Putin. Despite being pages of
peacemaking journey, their
meetings didn't produce any
breakthroughs when it comes to
Russia's war on Ukraine. Joining
us now max boot, a senior fellow
at the council on foreign
relations columnist for the
Washington post. Max good to see
you this morning certainly did
produce plenty of photo ops,
which was good. I think for both
sides in terms of what they
wanted out of it when we look at
those oh, where this puts the
world John Kirby, saying we
can't reasonably look at China
is impartial in any way earlier
this week. This relationship he
was noting is more about pushing
back against the west,
particularly pushing back
against the us what's your level
of concern about this deepening
relationship between China and
Russia? I am concerned, but I'm
not panicked. I might start to
hit the panic button of China or
actually just start providing
munitions for Russia and
particularly our artillery
shells and missiles. Russia is
running low on both of those
types of munitions. They
desperately need them from
somewhere. If China were to
provide them that could really
tilt the balance of power in the
war in Ukraine. That is not
happening so far, China is
providing economic support to
Russia in the form of microchips
and cell phones and other things
that are now embargoed by the
west. And of course, China is
benefiting from oil that Russia
sells to China. But it's still
very much a limited partnership,
and it's something that is a
certainly of concern, but it's
not. What China is doing is not
a game changer in the war in
Ukraine. What about on a broader
level? Are there specific signs
that you'll be looking for in
the coming weeks and months? In
terms of this relationship
between the two beyond the
Orange, where it warned Ukraine
I think that's the big one. Is
China going to step forward and
provide weapons to Russia? Which
is something that the been
administration has warned about
. But you know, China has been
reluctant to do that. And I
think what we're seeing is that
, although before the war, China
and Russia proclaimed this
limitless friendship, there are
actually sharp limits on their
partnership, and you didn't see
them talking about limitless
partnership. During XI's visit
to Moscow. In fact, it's a very
limited partnership where they
both want to triangulate against
the United States. They see them
what the us has their common
enemy, but they also have a lot
of divisions, and one of the big
ones is that China is
economically dependent on trade
. It's the largest trading
nation in the world, and it
needs to trade with the united
States it needs to trade with
Europe. It does not want to
become as isolated as sanctioned
as Russia is, and so there are
sharp limits so far on how far
she is willing to go to buddy up
to this indicted war criminal in
the Kremlin, looking
specifically Ukraine Ukrainians
have said they are trying to
organize a call between she and
president zelensky. If that call
were to happen. Do you see
anything coming of it? Very
little, but I do think it would
be a way for China to pretend to
be quote unquote, a peacemaker,
which is something that is part
of GE's kind of diplomatic
offensive right now. Just
recently, China brokered a deal
between Saudi Arabia and Iran to
restore diplomatic relations,
which I think was a positive
step forward. And that's been
sort of the cover for ji and his
visit to Russia is that he is
advancing this Chinese peace
plan. I don't I don't see any
real there's no real evidence
that the Chinese peace plan is
going to produce peace, but
obviously it would be a pr win
for G, and it will at least
create are some some. You know
some fodder for propaganda so
that he can claim he's not just
sticking with Russia. He's
actually trying to act as a
peacemaker. And so I hope he
does talk to president zelensky
. I think that would restore a
tiny bit of balance in that
relationship. It would be
interesting to have that readout
to in terms of what is actually
discussed because obviously the
peace plan that has been that
we've heard about in terms of
GE's police plan. There are some
very clear dealbreakers there
for Ukraine. Yeah. I mean,
basically, the Chinese peace
plan would freeze positions in
class, which would allow Russia
to continue occupying 20% of
Ukraine and definitely, and
obviously, that's a deal breaker
. From the standpoint of Ukraine
. I think the actual the one
thing that China is actually
done for pieces that she has
made clear he does not approve
of Putin's nuclear saber
rattling. And since she made
that clear last fall, you really
have not heard Putin engage in
those kinds of nuclear threats.
So that is the one positive
thing that China has done. Um,
but otherwise ah, it's been
largely on the side of Russia,
although in a limited kind of
way, not not offering Putin
everything that he wants. Did
Russia get enough out of this
visit? I you know, it's
certainly not as much as Putin
wants. I mean, he desperately
wants China to come forward with
artillery shells and other
munitions that help the war
effort, and he's not getting
that. But what he is getting is
a big hug and embrace at a time
when he has becoming recognized
as an international criminal and
a pariah. You know, last week
you had the international
criminal court, actually
indicting Putin, and so they're
not going to be any western
leaders who are going to be
joining the Moscow but this is a
way for Putin to signal that he
is not isolated, but he has an
alternative to the west, and he
is he is cozying up to China,
but he's doing so in a very
subservient position, you know,
at the beginning of the cold
war, Russia was the big brother
in China was the little brother